yeah I'm going to talk about glycolysis
and new glucose Genesis glycolysis is
the first step towards that glucose
utilization for energy so glycolysis
takes place in all living cells like
it's a mammalian cell or it's a plant
sale or a bacteria everywhere glycolysis
is the first step towards energy the
energy production so the substrate for
glycolysis is glucose and glucose is
converted by ten step enzymatic pathway
to pyruvate and later that pyruvate is
utilized in the mitochondria for further
energy utilization
however we will study how glucose is
converted to pyruvate step by step and
glycolysis is very important pathway
because cancer cell use mainly
glycolysis as their energy part for
their energy purpose they doesn't use
mitochondria to yield energy so let's go
step by step
so the first substrate is glucose and
it's important to note that the all the
enzymatic reactions for this metabolic
pathway that means the glycolysis takes
place in the cytoplasm of a cell so the
first reaction is glucose converted to
glucose 6-phosphate as you can see it's
a ring structure of glucose and the hexa
kinase enzyme as its kindness it
transfers a phosphate group from ATP to
this sixth position and it
simultaneously ATP get converted into
adp so the second step is glucose
6-phosphate
get converted to fructose 6-phosphate so
this is the isomerization reaction
because glucose and fructose
they are isomer of each other so this is
the key to isomer it sees the Aldo's
isomer so and this enzyme must be an
isomerase so this enzyme is
phosphofructokinase and as you can see
from the structure the structure just
isomerized
but the carbon number remain the same
what happened fructose 6-phosphate it's
getting converted to fructose 1 6
bisphosphate remember here again another
phosphate is added to the substrate and
again the enzyme is another kinase here
phosphofructokinase with the help of
this enzyme ATP is hydrolyzed to ADP and
the phosphate group is added towards one
first position of the glucose and after
that aldolase breaks this six carbon
product into two three carbon sugars one
is a loose and another is ketose first
and O's is named as glyceraldehyde 3
phosphate and glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
this is the structure of the crystal
aldehyde in the third position you can
see there is a phosphate group attached
and also it's converted to
dihydroxyacetone phosphate it is a
structure of the dihydroxyacetone
phosphate two phosphates are there and
these two sugars they are
interconvertible by isomer as enzyme so
from this glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
another very important enzyme that is
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate dehydrogenase
or popularly known as gap th it will
convert this early height 3 phosphate
into 1 3 phosphoglycerate and in this
step nad is converted to NADH and this
step is very important because the NADH
produced in this step would be later
utilized in the electron transport chain
to produce further ATP and in the next
step 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate here you
can see the structure would be converted
it is 2 phosphate group and first one
carbon and then third carbon and this is
going to convert it into 3
phosphoglycerate and this step is
catalyzed by phosphoglycerate kinase and
this kindness enzyme is a little bit
different
it doesn't take phosphate group from the
ATP instead it takes the phosphate group
from the substrate and it's give to ATP
so in this step ATP is produced from ADP
so this step is called substrate level
phosphorylation phosphorylation this
step is called substrate level
phosphorylation because the from the
substrate this kinase enzyme takes
phosphate and phosphorylates adp into
ATP so it's taking up phosphate from the
substrate and putting it into ADP to
form ATP that is adenosine triphosphate
and this step is ATP so this step is
crucially important and this enzyme this
phosphoglycerate kinase is very
important enzyme
however when phosphoglycerate kinase
convert it into 3 phosphoglycerate it
gets further converted to
2-phosphoglycerate then again converted
to phosphoenolpyruvate after
phosphoenolpyruvate another important
enzyme pyruvate kinase it converts
phosphoenolpyruvate to pyruvate and in
again in this step substrate level
phosphorylation takes place as earlier i
have said that substrate level
phosphorylation is the method by which
ATP is generated in the glycolysis so
you can see again ATP is generated that
means pyruvate kinase enzyme 2 phosphate
from the substrate and phosphorylated
adp to get ATP and this pyruvate would
be later transferred into the
mitochondria for further processing by
the Krebs cycle so in this whole
reaction there are two steps where we
need ATP for the energy source for the
fuel this reaction for fueling this
reaction ATP is initially required so
two molecules of ATP is required at
first but in the payoff phase actually
there are four molecules of ATP is
produced
and as earlier I have said two molecules
of ATP is utilized earlier so net gain
of ATP in this reaction is 4 minus 2
equal to 2 ATP remember the NADH
produced here would not yield ATP direct
here this NADH will enter mitochondria
and in the electron transport chain this
NADH will produce a PP okay so next we
are going to talk about new glucose
Genesis nucleo Genesis is just reversal
of glycolysis but not exact reversal
there are 3 steps which are different
from glycolysis as you can see if we can
draw a schematic from glucose to a 10
step process to pyruvate then the new
glucose Genesis would go from pyruvate
to glucose but there are 3 steps 1 2 & 3
in these 3 steps the reaction is not
exact reverse because these 3 steps are
unidirectional means these steps are not
reversible that is why separate enzymes
are required to bypass this step and to
produce glucose from pyruvate now what
happens pyruvate entered the
mitochondria after glycolysis here you
can see pyruvate has entered the
mitochondria so when bukas level is low
or somehow body needs glucose new
glucose Genesis will take this 4 new
glucose Genesis pyruvate carboxylase is
the crucial enzyme so pyruvate
carboxylase as the name suggests
carboxylase it will add a carboxyl group
and it will just put a carboxyl group
into the pyruvate it will convert it
into the oxaloacetic acid remember this
this is a 3 carbon but oxaloacetate acid
or oxaloacetate it's 4 carbon so it's a
step up reaction
and this pyruvate carboxylase actually
facilitated the step up reaction in
pyruvate carboxylase
it's a mitochondrial enzyme it required
biotin for carboxylation and this is a
low acetic acid it gets out again into
the cytoplasm and get converted by
carboxykinase to phosphoenolpyruvate and
from phosphoenolpyruvate
these steps are reversible these steps
are reversible so it can go up to
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate but it cannot
get converted to fructose 6-phosphate in
the straight manner because the step
catalyzed by phosphofructokinase it's
not reversible reaction in this step is
not reversible that is why there is a
bypass of this step is done by fructose
1 6 bisphosphate ace it is a phosphatase
enzyme so it will remove the phosphate
from this fructose 1 6 bisphosphate and
it will convert it into fructose
6-phosphate again the step from glucose
6-phosphate to glucose it's not
reversible so we need a different bypass
route for conversion of glucose
6-phosphate
into glucose and that is catalyzed by
glucose-6-phosphatase again it's a
phosphorous enzyme so it will cleave
phosphate and yield glucose so why we
need gluconeogenesis suppose our body
glucose level is low and we need to make
glucose from other sources so what could
be other sources for glucose like in the
muscle lactate is produced due to
anaerobic respiration this left it could
be converted into pyruvate and that
pyruvate could be further converted into
glucose or others wise many plutonic
amino acid which ultimately leads
glucose Angelica - it's like an alanine
which ultimately get converted to
pyruvate will also lead to formation of
glucose from this pyruvate and this
process is known as new gluco Genesis so
our body maintains our exact balance
between gluconeogenesis and glycol is
so insulin is a hormone which prevents
gluconeogenesis but other hormones like
glucagon it help in gluconeogenesis and
let's conclude the video hope you liked
it comment subscribe and bye